only doing enough or with me now is Marc
Vlessing he's chief executive of Pocket
living which builds pre-pack starter
homes in London more very good evening
to you what would the I catches for you
presume you're quite happy with this
extension of stamp duty relief to shared
ownership I think that was a good good
news story for first-time buyers that
there was also a little bit in the red
book afterwards in which they decided to
extend the help to buy program for first
time buyers until 2023 and that was
exceptionally good news for that market
segment you think the housing sector is
ever gonna win itself off how to buy oh
yes I'm sure you've mastered it it's not
a long-term solution to getting us out
of the trouble that we're in what was
really interesting I thought about the
budget was a recognition that the extra
housing that the country desperately
needs needs to come from the new
verticals as I call them so more from
the housing associations more from SME
builders more from local authorities of
course now been released to build on
their own land they've been allowed to
borrow against their balance sheets
that's really big news there's that risk
some councils borrowing over their heads
Oh getting into financial difficulties
if house prices then subsequently take a
downturn
I think the Treasury has been
controlling the finances of the local
authorities in such a long time they're
not going to let them do that in a hurry
but it will make a difference to have
you know in the 50s in the sixties when
we were for once building enough housing
in this country it was because the
council's were also building so we do
need to get them back in the game do you
think local forces have forgotten how to
build big big housing projects I mean
clearly they've never stopped building
council houses but they haven't done it
to any scale for decades now you know I
think that's a really good point
it's gonna take them a long time to
build up the teams that they need it's
taken my company pocket living ten years
to build a really great team with which
we're now building quite a lot of
starter housing in London so it's not
going to happen overnight and I think
that the name of the game is going to
have to be partnerships they're going to
have to want to work with those SME
builders and developers that are coming
out of the stocks as well well you've
got a quite a lot of work on the go here
in London I mean how do you find local
London authorities to deal with
increasingly receptive I mean I there
really has been an important shift in
thinking around housing in this country
and particularly in London
the idea that we have only two forms of
housing open market housing unbridled
Victorian capitalism almost and social
housing doesn't fit with a modern
housing market so I think local
authorities policymakers politicians our
stomachs understand that they need more
variety in between those two extremes
and you know whatever you want to call
that whether it's an immediate housing
starter housing key workout for some
people that's rented housing that's
discounted for other people that shared
ownership in the case of pocket its
discount at home that sold only to
people on particularly incomes and also
and also you target key workers quite a
lot don't you yes so about 50% of the
housing that we build get sold to people
in the public sector or in the voluntary
sector but there are lots of people in
the private sector of course who are
modest incomes who need to be able to
get themselves on the housing ladder as
well
because one of the other things that
Philip Hammond did yesterday he said
that part of this high street fund is
going to enable empty shops to be
converted into housing is that going to
shift the dial it's not going to shift
the dial but it's I think it's important
that we try a little bit of anything
because there is no silver bullet for
the scale of problem that we have I mean
there's such a tremendous imbalance
between supply and demand in this
country in other words not enough supply
versus the demand that we have but
you've got to try a little bit of
everything and I think again that's
where government and this is not just
this government I think successive
governments over the last 10 15 years
have woken up to the fact that it's
about lots of little initiatives across
the board that hopefully will add up to
I would say a 50% increase in housing
from where we are today any other very
short measures that you'd have
introduced I'd like to see them get more
excited still about modular housing I
mean it's it's very easy to get excited
about that the pictures in the cranes
and hasn't going up very quickly and
they make for very good photo calls I do
think we need a planning brakes blessing
from [ __ ] living godly with them
afraid